whatever I'm running the pick-and-roll
and I leave my feet he'll pull me to the
side and say stop jumping in the air
keep your dribble so how much of the
game are you I was watching and Alonzo
ball was just running to buy yeah yes by
a Beverly look at the density
yep telling us that patrick beverley
pounding
ronzo ball all over the war is going to
be a great learning experience and
martin he gets a turnover and this in my
opinion is a way to get to the lead
again don't he doesn't take it
personally this is Jesse ventrally is in
talking to continent walk before the
game he said yeah I walk by young guy
walked into the fire right away because
it's going to be a grind every single
time their workers
Beverly de gallo Mexican is left hill
and the Lakers realize their faith
Thank You Beverly haunting the ground
hugging is getting out on the course
the represen no no no guys treads
getting into it to heart
well done lay it in the basket look out
that's a big-time win Ralph
I think the Lakers came together and
gave it a shot here tonight but Clippers
just better in the second half
executed got stops and a good road win
here at Staples Center for a single
minute Conley gets it right back
[Applause]
the other day is not afraid anybody and
big onesome
his teammates good luck now he played to
the crowd
these night might be over after that
patrick beverley is optimistic listed at
six one one eighty five and bead is over
seven feet tall over 260 pounds a lot of
guys take exception to the
extracurriculars on plays of Patrick
Beverley but you're right he ain't
afraid to anybody and that's part of the
reason why he gets under players skin
man oh man see wooden bead was out of
punch or just a push we're gonna do some
looking at some TV back in Secaucus New
Jersey and beat angry driftin we'll go
all the way and to his credit will not
go rubbing salt in the moon by a slam
dunk
Patrick Beverley heavenwards former
teammates Wow
so we as a gamma before the game here we
have some drama after the game exchange
there a pleasant one with Harrell and
with Lou Williams from Blake Griffin
it's a big big win for Blake no flexin
bond 244 points he was on he was
definitely something tonight 44 points
and eight rebounds five at warriors up
10 the matchup of Patrick Beverley and
Kevin Durant his job is to frustrate
trying to irritate trash talk at the end
of the day both guys have tremendous
respect for one another
Bohlander and reports out of durant
they're both out they both have just
thrown out of the game
double technicals which is automatic
because it's a second tech for both
[Applause]
quick injection and maloi wasted no time
they've obviously been warned with that
first double technical
and it was starting to get out of hand
between those two
Loran is done
to the night with 23 points Beverly's
done for the night
[Applause]
and this would have been just a tech on
the rant by going towards bevels once
Bentley gets up and does his part and
that's both God
I would say this go against the game too
if I'm one of the referee I'm setting it
sold right away
[Music]
[Applause]
exactly ed Malloy not wasting time and
the right the right move no question I
wants to post up Beverly again
[Applause]
[Music]
offensive player who just can't defend
them
Patrick Beverley right now Emily just
who's a good defensive player Beverly
sensing that very aggressive defense
just took him to the bass oh we got to
get a replay up back to Beverly doing
the rocking the baby on the way down the
court rock that baby he